Speaker 1: but hey, folks, there are a couple
of bright spots.
And one of the bright spots that we're seeing
in the United States today is that it appears
that the Republican Party to a tiny, tiny
degree, appears to be warming up to the idea
of renewable energy.
There was a great op ed in the Hill this week
where they actually talked about a piece of
legislation that Republicans are pushing in
North Carolina without Democratic input.
But this piece of legislation would shut down
five major coal fired power plants in North
Carolina in the coming decade, cutting carbon
dioxide emissions and improving air quality.
Importantly, the legislation mandates the
main North Carolina utility, Duke Energy,
securitize the cost of coal retirements.
That provision will save ratepayers from paying
the retirement costs of those facilities and
is something that could be replicated in other
states across the country.
To date, only a few other states have adopted
a similar policy.
The bill would grow renewable energy substantially
by 4700 megawatts over the next decade, including
from solar power and offshore wind able to
power millions of homes.
So we know North Carolina is a purple state.
And you've got a Democratic governor and a
Republican controlled legislature, but this
bill was crafted without the input of Democrats
in the state of North Carolina.
And it actually includes we're going to close
down some coal plants and we're going to create
renewable energy.
And Republicans did it on their own.
As somebody who has spent 17 years covering
environmental news, reporting on it, writing
it, investigating it.
I'm almost in shock, folks, I am almost legitimately
in shock.
Because I never thought we'd see the day.
Honestly, truly, 17 years writing about misinformation
on climate change, coming from the right,
writing about fossil fuel donations and how
they're paying off politicians, I'm so incredibly
inspired by this piece of legislation.
And of course, we can quibble all day, does
it go far enough?
No, probably not.
But you know what, guys?
Sometimes you got to take a win is a win.
And I'm sick and tired of the all or nothing
types.
Sometimes even a little progress is something
to be celebrated, because you know what, when
you celebrate the small victories and the
folks see you out there congratulating them
and applauding them for doing the small steps,
do you know what it encourages them, encourages
them to do?
Take another step, do it again, do more.
And sometimes that's what we need to do.
More carrot, less stick.
Right.
So I'm not going to criticize this piece of
legislation right now, if they can get this
passed and they can shut down some of those
Duke Energy coal fired power plants in the
state of North Carolina, then more power to
them, replace it with renewable energy.
That's even better.
This is a good piece of legislation.
And I think we need to be celebrating that
fact, we get so few victories, especially
for the environment folks.
So I think we need to celebrate when that
opportunity arises, when it presents itself,
take advantage of it, because, again, we don't
get a lot of this and hopefully other Republicans
around the country take note.
The issue of climate change has been partizan
here in the United States for too long, but
ironically, it's actually not that partizan
when you go out to the voters themselves.
Majority of Republicans support actions to
protect the environment from the effects of
climate change.
They support renewable energy, as do obviously
huge majorities of Democrats.
And that's the thing like when you go out
there to the people, there's not this same
divide that you see in Washington, D.C. that
is not representative of the actual country.
So that's where my hope lies, my hope lies
in the people, and I think if we continue
to applaud these steps and more and more people
do that.
We might just start getting some good legislation
and of course, the infrastructure bill, right,
that has investments in renewable, we had
some Republicans vote to support it.
That's a good thing.
Renewable energy equals jobs for the United
States.
You know, if you want to look at it, not in
terms of environmental impact, if you want
to look at it in dollars and cents, it makes
perfect sense and it makes a lot of sense
as well.
Celebrate the victories when you can, folks,
because again, too few and far between